So, to review everybody,
we have a server that wants
to communicate with a device.
Now, you already know how
to create an Android app.
You're learning that now, obviously.
And, we just covered
downstream messaging,
where the server sends messages to
the device, so we're good there.
But you probably want to look in to
how to build a server at some point,
because I didn't teach you that.
You also might be wondering about when
the device wants to send a message
to the server.
Although I didn't cover it, Google
Cloud Messaging does support this and
you can learn more
from the documentation.
So check out the links and
the instruction notes everybody and
good work.